this video is sponsored by legal soup
[ __ ] Legal Zoom at the end of the video
a wisecrack just your friendly
neighborhood Jared here confession I've
watched every single episode of the 1977
spider-man TV show more than once don't
judge me okay maybe your judgment is
earned no it isn't this is awesome but
in all seriousness I really dig
spider-man and the thing that constantly
draws me back no matter how many times
the franchise is rebooted is just how
American spider-man truly is the
American flag now I don't mean that
Spidey loves pickup trucks and double
cheeseburgers but rather that he
embodies fundamental elements of
American ideology cat captain big fan
spider-man so cute that patriotic music
and welcome to this amazingly American
wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
spider-man now yes many superheroes from
Batman to Captain America embody
different aspects of American values
standing up for the little guy fighting
for what's right adhering to a strict
moral code but spider-man does so in a
way that uniquely reflects America's
role in the world just look at Peter
Parker a young kid coming of age who
suddenly gifted an insane amount of
power he's constantly wrestling with how
to wield this power or well if he even
should Parker mirrors America a young
country that post-world war ii happened
upon a massive amount of power and
constantly grapples with how to
responsibly wield this newfound power if
it should at all america doesn't have a
long history to draw upon for moral
direction just as Peter doesn't have any
parents to guide him in fact the only
piece of advice Peters ever given comes
from Uncle Ben you know the line with
great power
comes great responsibility Uncle Ben's
famous words reflect many ideas inherent
to American exceptionalism you know the
idea that America is dope AF and thus
has a duty to lead the world this idea
is encapsulated by the city upon a hill
a metaphor taken from the New Testament
by American colonists to describe their
mission to be a beacon of hope to the
rest of the world it's you still
continues for example the eyes of all
people are truly upon us and our
governments must be as a city upon a
hill constructed and inhabited by man
aware of their great trust and their
grave responsibilities or this Ronald
Reagan speech the past few days when
I've been at that window upstairs I've
thought a bit of The Shining City upon a
hill this view of America has been
reflected in each spider-man film from
Tobey Maguire to Andrew Garfield to
likely Tom Holland in each adaptation
Peter struggles with the weight of his
sudden powers yet feels a moral
responsibility to use them justly a
dilemma that mirrors two American
philosophies the reluctant Sheriff and
the American Jeremiah
the reluctant Sheriff first proposed by
American diplomat Richard Haass
basically takes your standard grizzled
Clint Eastwood cowboy and applies it to
u.s. global policy the US doesn't want
to enforce international order but since
there isn't anyone else as powerful we
got to suck it up and govern the out of
the rest of the world but simply the
u.s. doesn't want to regulate global
politics but must do so to prevent the
rising tide of violence
similarly Peter Parker both the Maguire
and Garfield versions isn't even sure he
wants to be spider-man yet ultimately
feels obligated much of the drama stems
from Peter struggled to balance his
personal life with his duty as a
superhero in spider-man Peter barely
makes it to his Thanksgiving dinner
because he's recovering from a fight
with the Green Goblin and in the amazing
spider-man 2 Peter's late to his own
high-school graduation because he's got
to fight Paul Giamatti or something
according to Hoss the reluctant Sheriff
must also create a posse people who work
with the sheriff for the good of their
town spider-man works with New Yorkers
to create his own kind of posse in
spider-man New Yorkers throw debris off
the Queensboro Bridge to distract the
Green Goblin in spider-man to the train
commuters keep spider-man's identity a
seat
great tell nobody in the amazing
spider-man all the New York City crane
operators aid Spidey in web slinging
across town and in the amazing
spider-man 2 the fire department helps
spider-man to fight electro even still
the weight of being spider-man is too
much for Peter in spider-man 2 Peter
just flat-out says he can no longer
carry on being a superhero because it's
ruining his personal life I want a life
of my own
and in the amazing spider-man 2 Peter
makes a similar confession to Gwen I
know there's a million reasons why we
shouldn't be together
well I've gotta make a choice and here's
where the American jeremiad kicks in
according to thinkers Sackman bercovich
and william feasts Panos
the american jeremiad emphasizes that
it's the u.s. is god-given mission to
save this world it's like the reluctant
Sheriff - the reluctance if we lose our
focus for even half a second or think
that someone else might pick up the
slack of spreading democracy godliness
morality the world could literally end
which to a lesser extent is exactly what
happens in each spider-man film take
Uncle Ben's death when Peter lets a
thief get away who could've taken that
guy I missed the part where that's my
problem
his moral inaction leads to his uncle's
demise forever reminding Peter that if
he doesn't live up to his ethical
mission people will die
likewise when Peter quits being
spider-man the bad guy power vacuum
immediately fills in in spider-man 2
during our hero's absence the crime rate
spikes and Doc Ock is able to rebuild
his doomsday reactor when Doc captures
Mary Jane and the reactor becomes an
existential threat to the city Peter
realizes he must be spider-man to save
millions of lives even after Peter and
MJ become official they recognized that
it's his duty to protect the city okay
thank you similarly after Gwen's death
forces Peter to quit in the amazing
spider-man 2 the Green Goblin builds up
a network of supervillains including the
weird mech Rhino Giamatti dude the film
ends with Peter realizing that without
spider-man the city is doomed
to escalating violence even with this
consistency between adaptations some
elements seem to shift in conjunction
with American values after all the
political climates surrounding each
series were pretty different so it's not
surprising that there would be a shift
in how heroics are displayed Tobey
Maguire spider-man largely uses what's
known in international relations as hard
power he rushes into battle relying on
brute strength to stop his foes there's
no time for negotiation with the Green
Goblin Doc Ock and the Sandman just some
good old-fashioned fisticuffs Andrew
Garfield however offers a soft power
version of spider-man he's constantly
trying to persuade his enemies to stop
their nonsense I can see that you don't
want to hurt anybody this difference
highlights a central contradiction
within the discourse of America
identity moral righteousness through
strength versus moral righteousness
through leadership in the face of 9/11
moral absolutes were demanded with the
Bush administration's with us or against
us rhetoric Obama's election however
brought with it a youthful feel tied to
messages of hope and change as such
Garfield spider-man uses more persuasive
tactics to deal with votes so how will
the newest iteration reflect the
American values of today well there's
really no telling until we see
homecoming but it seems that Tom
Hollands spider-man made distance itself
from the American jeremiad or reluctant
Sheriff unlike the Maguire and Garfield
films Hollands spider-man is no longer
the only hero on the block but one of
many this shift reflects different
models of how the global stage can and
should operate you see in a unipolar
world there's one central power that
keeps everybody in line many argue that
our current world is exactly this and
the u.s. is not only that central power
but it should be that central power aka
the American jeremiad but the world
wasn't always unipolar and some argue
that it shouldn't be in a multipolar
world there is no head honcho but an
assortment of nations with varying
economic and military strengths who
coalesce into alliances sort of like say
the Avengers Hall in spider-man now just
one of many superheroes imagines this
multipolar vision he's no longer needed
to be the beacon of hope and goodness
because there's a dozen other
superheroes who can pick up the slack
heck spider-man's even told by Starks to
sit out the remainder of the Civil War
fight Konoha Michael Aunt May you're
done in the trailers for spider-man
homecoming Tony doubles down on this
advice telling Peter that he's in way
over his head and that he should just
stay in New York can't you just be a
friendly neighborhood spider-man aside
from the political shift between Maguire
man and Garfield man there's also an
economic shift reflected between the two
series the Maguire films constantly
highlight Peters working-class status
Peter lives in a small house within a
blue-collar neighborhood that Aunt May
struggles to pay off his poor Uncle Ben
has recently been fired
downsizing the people and upsizing net
profit and everyone in the family is
looking for work in spider-man 2 Peter
fails as a pizza delivery boy lived in a
flophouse with a shared bathroom and
makes a pittance from the Daily Bugle
yet the original trilogy valorizes
Peters poverty endowing objects like
Aunt May's modest wedding ring with a
certain sentimental value that trumps
any kind of monetary value
I know Peters money problems are often
used as a source of levity really sorry
sorry doesn't pay the rent playfully
affirming the idea that struggling is
just a step towards the American Dream
just look at the difference between
Peter and Eddie Brock Peter keeps his
head down and just does the work whereas
antagonist Eddie uses flattery as stupid
little dream working with one of the
greatest newspaper editors of our time
and fake photos to get ahead of course
by the end of spider-man 3 Eddie gets
unceremoniously fired and then well
blown the hell of it
the valorisation of humble poverty
becomes especially obvious at the end of
spider-man 2 when Mary Jane rushes away
from her marriage to a successful
astronaut and chooses instead to be with
the broke as a joke Peter this resonates
with the early 2000s economy well it
wasn't terrific there was arguably a
semblance of hope the idea of keeping
your head down and working your way out
of poverty was a bit more popular than
it would be during and after the Great
Recession yet by the time the Amazing
Spiderman came around in 2012 four years
after the 2008 Great Recession being
poor lost much of its glamour the
housing crisis that Aunt May fictionally
fights against in spider-man 2 becomes
all too real for much of the US as such
Peters poverty is rarely spoken of in
these films his dad is now a rich
scientist with a private jet and his
Uncle Ben and Aunt May have a pretty
nice house instead the amazing
spider-man highlights Peters nerdy and
Genuity he's a science wizard designing
his own web shooters and assisting the
genius dr. Connors at Oscorp this Peter
doesn't have to grind away at Joe's
pizza so what will spider-man homecoming
happens
or for us we've seen major political
changes in the last year and the economy
seems to be doing pretty well or at
least the stock market is will
homecoming reflect this in its own
unique way or just offer us some good
old-fashioned mindless ass-kicking will
the younger aunt may be characterized as
a struggling single parent will the
Daily Bugle look like BuzzFeed let us
know what you think in the comments
thanks for watching guys peace
what's up wisecrack thanks for watching
with all this talk about great
responsibility you want to make sure
that you get your legal matters done
right LegalZoom is the smart way to
handle all your legal essentials and
Legal Zoom is giving wisecrack fans 15%
off their purchase whether it's setting
up a new business or planning family
matters they'll help you sling through
the process like it's nothing
LegalZoom eliminates the need to rely on
spidey-senses alone to snag an attorney
you trust or figure out how much your
legal work will cost and best of all
they get rid of those unnecessary trips
to a lawyer's office LegalZoom works
with a network of independent attorneys
to help you with all sorts of projects
the formation of your company wills and
trusts trademarks and patents contracts
and more when we decided to do wisecrack
full-time the most important step was
making sure our business was set up
right separating personal stuff from the
company and navigating all the
intricacies of state and local laws can
be a huge pain not to mention trying to
figure out how to trademark our logo but
LegalZoom offers the services and
resources to make sure you get it done
right so head over to legalzoom.com
slash wisecrack at the link in the
description below and bring all your
business copyright trademark and family
planning questions you'll get 15% off
your purchase just for being a fan of
what we do thanks a ton to LegalZoom for
sponsoring this video that's all for now
wisecrack don't forget to subscribe and
help us get to 2 million subscribers
because I'm going to Fogo de Chao and
I'm dreaming about that parmesan pork
and ring that bell so you don't miss a
thing peace guys
[Music]